It's great to welcome to the program today.
Back to the program. I should say, Dr. John
Gardner, founder of duty to warn co editor
of rocket man and nuclear madness and the
mind of Donald Trump. Uh, he taught in the
department of psychiatry at Johns Hopkins
medical center for 28 years. John, great to
have you back on today.
Great to be back. I really enjoyed being on
the show.
So listen, I don't even know where to start
because since you were last on it, you know,
you've been tracking what is a, um, a concerning
behavior by the president of the United States
from a mental health perspective. We had this
unexpected visit to Walter Reed hospital in
November. Uh, we don't have any particular
reason to think that it was mental health
or cognitive related specifically, but we
don't really have a very clear answer as to
why he did go. The idea that it was getting
a jump on next year's physical is hard to
believe at best. Um, what, what are you seeing
over the last few months? How much have you
been looking at this Walter Reed thing?
Well, actually, uh, go to the Walter Reed
thing. I have a theory about this based on
no facts, although apparently it was reported
that he had reported some kind of chest pains,
um, that had been reported. I don't know if
it'd been verified.
I saw that it was speculated and denied by
the white house, but their denials don't mean
very much.
Don't mean anything. Right. Oh, what they
deny, they confirm in most cases. Um, but,
uh, actually given his a fast food diet and
as being overweight and as being high on the
cholesterol, that's not unsurprising, but
actually a lot of people don't realize this,
but chest pains is one of the most common
presentations at an emergency room. And 90%
of the time it's a panic attack. Right. So
all of this started when the impeachment stuff
started heating up. So my theory based, I
guess I say on speculation is he may have
experienced chest pains as his presenting
problem, but really he was having a panic
attack actually, if he was having a panic
attack, that might be the most reality centered
thing that he's done.
Well, that's why I actually, I actually speculated
that it may have been one of those situations
where you feel like you're a heart attack
and they do tests and the doctor comes out
and says, you didn't have a heart attack.
I think that this was a panic attack. The
what makes me skeptical about that is it seems
that Trump lacks the personality traits that
would get him to actually panic because that
requires sort of some self awareness of the
situation you're in. Yeah.
Yeah. No, I think it's a very good point.
In fact, part of his personality disorder
is a lack of anxiety over being caught or
punished or, uh, that the psychopaths don't
seem to weigh the probable risks and consequences
of their behavior. Uh, you know, all these
people in jail, like, you know, uh, what did
they think they were? How did they think they
were even going to get away with it? You know,
but somehow they thought they were, so I agree
with you about that, but the walls are really
closing in on him. And this is one of the
reasons actually that we should be very, very
concerned right now. I mean, not, we predicted
this actually a couple of years ago and even
more strongly a year ago that this day of
reckoning would come, uh, that someday he
would be held accountable. We thought it was
going to be for the Mueller investigation.
It was, we didn't know that the Ukraine situation
was even going to emerge. We couldn't see
that in our crystal ball, but that once the
ass hit the fan, I don't know what you can
say, what words we can say on your platform,
uh, that, that, that he was going to de compensate,
uh, and that he would become even more dangerous
because first of all, the situation is his
cognitive decline has continued. He now, however,
has created a situation where there are no
safety on the gun. There are no adults in
the white house anymore. And this is what
these dictators do. They purge the government
and the bureaucracy of anyone who wasn't slavish
Lee loyal and, and sycophantic. Uh, so, uh,
not only in his administration, but there
we found out today that they, he's fired a
third of the diplomats, you know, I mean,
he's getting rid of anyone, not only the ones
in Ukraine that he tried to get rid of, uh,
but anyone who could possibly stand in his
way or say no, or offer a conflicting opinion
or provide expertise or information which
contradicts his crazy conspiracy theories.
All those people have been removed. And now
he's in a state of maximum agitation. As we
said in our last op-ed and USA today, we think
he may be even having a bit of a hypomanic
episode and that would kind of fit with the
chest pain thing, meaning his whole energy
level is now at a frantic pace. Um, and if
you look at his activities, they're becoming
even more erratic. I think most recently very
grammatically was this withdrawal from Syria.
Um, where he literally had a conversation
with the head of Turkey, president of Turkey,
and then pick up the phone and told the troops
to start withdrawing without discussing it.
He didn't even discuss it with one member
of his own administration.
No. Something like that. Could that just be
that he's ignorant and doesn't care what anyone
else thinks, but not necessarily of a, of
a cognitive concern?
Well, I think here the, it's really the psychiatric
point I was making here is that there's something
impulsive and accelerated. So there's something
manic about his decision making now. And actually
if you read the descriptions of his tweets,
this is when they impeachment. I'm saying
just started heating up. People were commenting
on the tweets being manic. That was one of
the words people kept using to describe them
because he was like tweeting like 30 40 50
times a day, you know, with this sort of screed
that was completely off the hook. But in other
words, that's not abnormal for him. But now
he was doing it more and more quickly and
more and more rapidly and more free and more
frequently so that there's kind of a way in
which the water is boiling. Now the boiling
point has kind of, it's boiling over is what
I'm saying
in terms of the, so some of the policy stuff
can be sort of a proxy to his cognitive state,
but last time we talked, we had all of these
examples of the slurring, which we don't know
if this may be related to sort of a some kind
of drug abuse or cognitive decline. There
was him repeating that he wants to find the
oranges of an investigation and he repeated
it twice and you could see that his, he seemed
to have some recognition that he was saying
something that didn't make sense but sort
of unable to correct it. We had him getting
off of air force one and wandering away from
his car and having to be brought back. Something
similar happened in Argentina when he wandered
off stage after being introduced and shaking
hands with the president. Are we seeing more
of those things or are we mostly looking at
sort of through policy as a proxy?
No, actually in honor of your show, I, I made
a little sheet of the latest signs of cognitive
decline. First of all, I just want to point
out this excellent book from anonymous. Summarize
it very well. When they say he stumbles, he
slurs, he gets confused, he can't synthesize
information, he can't remember anything. And
this doesn't just happen sometimes. So that's
a summary. Um, but most recently in the past
few months, um, for example, when he was speaking
to the troops, this is just a, a month ago,
he said, our armed forces have always lived
by the words of Douglas MacArthur. You notice
in both those cases, he didn't finish the
word. Uh, this is really a phonetic paraphilia
that we really only see and people who are
either drunk or developing Alzheimer's, but
know there's an organic brain problem, either
temporary or permanent, but in this case it's
not temporary. So it can't be that he's drunk.
Okay. So let's look at that. That's actually
very interesting. So this is a symptom which
you as, as a mental health professional can
say. We, there is a limited number of explanations
for that particular symptom. And for example,
the alleged dyslexia that some suspect Trump
has, that would not be an a possible explanation
for that linguistic phenomena.
No, because people who I have dyslexia, as
a matter of fact, uh, I don't, um, miss cause
look at some of these other examples. Instead
of stock market, he said sock rocket. Uh,
he couldn't pronounce obsolete or applicable.
Uh, he said the, at NATO just this week that
U S has the most powerful, powerful military
in the world. He wants to say powerful. Yup.
B said power role. He couldn't finish the
word. So this kind of yes. So to get to your
point that we have a determined psychiatry,
that something can be past the pneumonic.
Meaning if someone has that symptom, we know
what the illness is. Cause there's, as you
say, a limited number of possibilities. There's
a very limited number possibilities for this
kind of breakdown and the ability to speak
English. And it's not just pronunciation,
it's also comprehension. Uh, so he's showing
a, a loss in his ability to comprehend and
the complexity of his sentences and his ability
to stay on topic without going off on a irrelevancy,
on his repetitions.
Repetition is actually a sign of, of cognitive
decline. And he keeps saying the same thing
over and over again. His use of superlatives,
everything's the greatest or the worst or
[inaudible]. There's no nuance in the words.
And also his memory. Remember he said his
father was born in Germany when it was his
grandfather that was born in Germany. Well,
he recently said to the president of Italy
who we call president mozzarella instead of
mozzarella. Okay. And said, we've been allies
since ancient Rome. I mean, he's getting time
to, you know, American didn't exist, you know,
that America was built with native Americans
during the time of ancient Rome. So in others
he's getting all these times confused and
places confused and names confused. It's,
it's, it's more of a generic breakdown. Even
his, even his balance is poor. Um, there's
a generic with Alzheimer's, there's a breakdown
in all of the cognitive functions, all of
them.
So is that actually, you mentioned the, so,
so let me bring up one other element related
to the Walter Reed visit. Let's, let's imagine
that we just don't know what the Walter Reed
visit was about. One of the things that was
observed afterwards was that he was getting
off of air force, one from the low stairs
rather than the high stairs. And that, uh,
at least one time when getting off of the
high stairs, he had a Senator walking right
next to him, really kind of keeping a butt
up against the railing. Again, propping him
up was the sort of colloquial way that it
was described. Does that tell us anything
in terms of how it might connect with what
you're discussing?
Yes. Loss of balance goes with it because
again, all of the mental functions are deteriorating,
including the ability to maneuver physically
in space, you know, uh, so his, uh, his, um,
stumbling verbally in a stumbling physically
or part of the same generic overall deterioration.
What would be the test that would determine
whether something is going on here?
Well, we've been calling for two years now
for him to get a neuro-psychological a battery
of tests. It's a, it's a battery of tests
that evaluate people psycho, their cognitive
functioning and a whole bunch of levels with
a whole bunch of different tasks. You know
what, we actually asked, uh, Rodney Rodney
Jackson, his doctor, we actually sent a letter
with 70 doctors asking him to give him, uh,
the MOCA, which he did, but any past the MOCA,
which he said proved he was a stable genius
and more intelligent than all past presidents,
which is a little bit like saying, uh, you
know, I passed a first grade exam and that
makes me Mensa, you know, it's, it's a most
kindergarteners, just to give you a sense,
can pass the mocha. It's things like, can
you identify a camel? Can you repeat three
words backwards?
Yeah. But are they the smart kindergartners?
No, the ones who couldn't do it, we would
hold them back. So, so, so it's true he hadn't
reached that level of dementia. But you know,
one of the people, uh, in the anonymous books
of the Trump is sort of like going to the
white house. It's kind of like going to a
nursing home and your uncle is running around
the courtyard without pants. I mean that was,
in other words, he's not at the point where
he is so demented that uh, he can't remember
his own name or what recognize his own children,
but he thinks his father was born in Germany
and he can't pronounce words and he doesn't
remember things they can't understand. So
he's given, this is a guy who used to go to
Ivy league schools, even if his dad got him
and he still went there and now he's really
fallen so far from his own baseline. And that's
one of the things that we use to determine
cognitive decline is different people have
different abilities, right? But we have to
compare someone to their own baseline. You
look at speeches he made in the 80s he sounds
extremely articulate and bright even though
he sounds like a jerk and you compare him
to now and you see that he's like lost like
30 or 40 IQ points.
What did you make? I don't know if you saw
this, but [inaudible] during the first impeachment
hearings, he went out and did one of the helicopter
press conference where he had notes about
what he reportedly told Gordon Sunland during
a phone call. And he seemed very erratic yelling,
I want nothing. No quit, you know, the very
strange kind of kind of like strained and
repeating over and over again was, was there
anything about that episode that either coincides
with or goes against the impression that you're
getting from his other behavior?
Well, first of all, the fact that he has to
have carry notes, right? Written in Sharpie
to say no quid pro quo. That's, it's almost
like the mocha that's four words forward.
He can remember four words without having
to refer to notes. Uh, so I think that's already
telling you something about his cognitive
level of, of, of functioning. And the other
thing I just want to say is he just saying
this is bizarre stuff. You know, like he was
saying yesterday that, you know, the next
president, they'll impeach him if he goes
to the refrigerator and gets oranges.
Right? But isn't, that just, isn't some of
this just Trump's personality?
You know, that's where it's really instructive
to look at the videos of him in the 80s, because
really he was literally the same jerk then
that he is now, because a personality disorder
is a lifetime disorder. You have it from the
time you're young and you have it till you
die. Um, and in his case, it's actually gotten
worse. We've talked about this in terms of
his malignant narcissism, the one malignant
narcissist game power, their grandiosity and
their paranoia as well as their sadism and
their anti so becomes inflamed because now
they feel empowered. Like he says, now I'm
president, I can do whatever I want, you know?
And so, uh, he's, his personality disorder
actually has gotten worse, but his cognitive
functioning, uh, is much worse than it was
when he was still a jerk as a young man. Uh,
so we really have now a series of forces that
are making him maximally dangerous right now.
You know, we were all kind of getting a laugh
out of how the world leaders were laughing
at him, at NATO. And it makes him laughing
at him. But remember Barack Obama laughing
at him that, you know, go to him to run for
president. This is a guy who gets even, okay.
So now he wants to get even with these guys
at NATO, our allies, you know, and he's already
been antagonistic, but I'm saying he feels
like he's on his back. He feels weakened.
He feels attacked. And so his response is
to do something more aggressive, more destructive,
to feel more powerful. And so all of the things
that are making him a wounded animal are making
him more dangerous now than he ever was.
We've been speaking with Dr. John Gardner,
founder of duty to warn co editor of rocket
man, nuclear madness, and the mind of Donald
Trump. He taught in the department of psychiatry
at Johns Hopkins medical center for nearly
30 years. Always. So great to have you on.
Yeah. Thank you.